guy michel viennent de prendre leur
appui ils veulent vendre leur maison
pour aller vivre à la campagne
il signe un contrat de six mois avec un
courtier immobilier
mais trois semaines plus tard valeur ils
découvrent une infiltration d'eau dans
le sous-sol de leur maison
le verdict tombe faut faire des travaux
importants pour trouver un acheteur
le courtier ils doivent passer leur pays
et vendre la maison sans garantie légale
ils font perdre des milliers de dollars
lisez michel décide alors de ne plus
vendre
sauf que le courtier le rappellent
qu'ils ont signé un contrat de vente de
six mois avec lui y at il une porte de
sortie pour eux oui ils peuvent mettre
leur résidence hors marché mettre sa
maison hors marché signifie que la junte
doit arrêter de faire toute publicité
sur la propriété et il ne peut pas
refuser
et attention le contrat est toujours en
vigueur
s'ils veulent vendre leur maison très
heureux même ou avec un autre courtier
lisez michel devront attendre la fin de
leur contrat dans six mois
le fin mot de l'histoire un contrat
c'est un contre un c'est vrai mais ce
n'est quand même pas une prison